there is nothing left to save for
bandana Patra and her family for hours
of cyclicamp on destroyed her home built
over a lifetime in West Bengal's States
the storm came the day before yesterday
and taught through our roof I was at
home at the time and I had to rush
outside for safety for farmers such as
Ram Prasad knuckle the loss of crops to
peak harvest season is devastating they
are trying to salvage whatever they can
to survive what looks like a daunting
summer ahead with their income we've
lost all our crops farmers have lost
their grains and their livestock the
situation is very bad India's Prime
Minister Narendra Modi flew into the
provincial capital Kolkata a city of 14
million people where repair crews are
racing to clear the wreckage of fallen
trees and tangled powerlines to switch
electricity supplies back on more these
under pressure to declare a national
disaster which would allow more federal
funds and support for the damaged states
of West Bengal and neighboring Auto Show
we're still allocating a hundred and
thirty-one million dollars to the state
of West Bengal at the moment so they
don't face any troubles in restoring
normalcy it's a similar picture of
devastation in neighboring Bangladesh
where coastal areas and districts were
also battered by cyclone oomph on social
distancing is difficult here with the
need for survival more pressing than the
threat of coronavirus 26 areas have been
affected and all 26 areas have reported
destruction it's still hard to assess
exactly how much damage has been caused
by the cyclone officials will let us
know in about seven days and there are
many remote areas including the
ecologically fragile thunderbirds
mangroves region of India and Bangladesh
which remain cut off and experts are
trying to assess just how much
the cyclone there has left behind
Priyanka Gupta al-jazeera tava Chaudhary
is in Dhaka with more on recovery
efforts in Bangladesh the Navy the Coast
Guard and the Army has been deployed to
take care of these people providing them
relief the big challenge and the
question still remains what to do with
all these people they don't have a home
to go back and this is in a situation
when the country is going to economic
challenge as well due to the shutdown
people have to be provided relief us to
be given 10 million people are without
electricity I mean all the mobile towers
are gone dikes have been washed away
Hatcher is about 180,000 Hatcher a
shrimp farming it's a big business in
southwest of Bangladesh it's totally
washed away farmland 146,000 of farmland
washed away so the government has to
think in a long term rather to
rehabilitate these people because they
don't have a god home to go back to and
keeping them in the shelter also is a
double-edged sword because this time of
pandemic for coronavirus so a major
challenge ahead for the country to deal
with this fallout from the cyclone
Ampang